welcome to this video playing Van
Nostrand International Master with no
flag so oops don't know where he's from
we have an advanced Cal con okay 91 yeah
maybe he's intending to do 93 and
therefore maybe well anyway I need to
play a c5 at some stage I cannot delay
it forever
they are ideas like night c8 nowadays
and I'd see 8b 6 and delayed is even
further but ok at some point I think I
need to I need to play the C pawn okay
let's see or maybe 93 here what yeah
it's not bad
he's protecting the two pawns no of
course I can't I can just take d3 and c5
but this is certainly I'm better for for
wide
hmm
not quite sure what I should do let's
play a non-committal move I don't really
want to take and take c5 if this looks
like white is just eternally better
react I could have taken I don't know
but take d3 Bishop d3 Bishop c5 there's
always Queen aji form quite um quite a
problem
okay
let's just delay that he probably
doesn't have an idea anyway to keep
those pawns forever
yeah qg4 why does some certainly better
yeah not sure how much but it certainly
something
our way the Heidi I cannot take nonsense
when I can take on t3 but it's not a
great move really don't you know maybe I
can tickle the Queen a bit trying to
force it to to worse positions
it's not so clear how that should go
queen h3 I was planning to play Knight
to f5 to provoke G form it's not clear
that g4 it's bad or anything but at
least it's um at least it's a move that
also entails some weaknesses on g4 I
want to play should be for was my idea
but I'm not sure g4 Bishop before maybe
you can can play I cannot take on h6
this now threatens 94 g5 I can just take
and Bishop h6 I hope it's not a thread I
mean I can take Queen takes and then at
least Bishop age 7 back and I don't see
I don't see the attack yeah maybe white
should think about them flag and let's
say c3 preparing preventing 94 and
stabilizing things 94 so annoying moves
okay yeah yeah I thought taking but it
gives it no just just drove it back
Trini doesn't make any sense to take
that the bishop becomes 2 d 3 and is
just very strong who again threatening
94 yeah
see three oh not these verse III is
there some other idea thinking about a
five move like that NIDA for no is quite
pointless okay come on let's not fall
asleep iam trying to activate pieces
attending nights afore I really not sure
that this is great or anything just at
least risky what I'm doing
yeah g5 now gets more dangerous but
nothing I could do about that how to
play now take here and play Queen to F -
the night is hanging yeah okay so this
line is really bad
how to activate him night see phone
anyway maybe 96 sorry I'm not a Nazi for
he takes g6 this is very ugly maybe I
should play h5 even yeah let's play h5
attending Bishop 36
or Bishop f5 and then v6 something like
that tries to de-stress to keep the
position closed for the moment and maybe
knight c6 c7 this could help yeah why
does in good shape this absolutely no
question not default so would be nice
but it always runs into a pinion some
rather drop back here cover g6 and I
also have this this irritating move
Queen f2 you know I will probably play
this next unless there's a really strong
strong threat
yeah do I can I have I really know maybe
maybe look h g3 to h3
time warning
John wanted to Queen f ones almost made
Jack
Jack whoops it's just as that blonde at
the Queen repeat Bishop b2 I obviously
didn't expect I can just take it but
okay at the end it was really a matter
of seconds now there are complicated
stuff probably I don't know actually the
computer likes black which surprises me
I have some play but it's not like it's
looking great you know this I can
probably take surprisingly the comp
always gives me a pretty clear advantage
white has got two pawns but okay it's
not it's not the greatest structure ever
hard to to get any concrete attack
alright thanks for watching